ALICIA WILLIAMS:
Today we're talking
about data sets, BigQuery,
and managing VMs.
I'm Alicia, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
With Google Cloud's
datasets, you
can access an ever-expanding
collection of data to support
and empower your
analyses and ML models.
The most recent addition is
all of Google Cloud's release
notes.
Make sure you bookmark this
blog post, because we're
keeping it up to date
with dataset news and best
practices.
Interested in checking
out those datasets
but aren't quite
sure where to start?
Leah has been busy bringing
us all kinds of tips
on how to architect and
administer BigQuery.
Whether you're new to BigQuery
or just looking to brush up,
these blogs and videos will help
you become a BigQuery expert.
The cloud is full of new and
exciting technologies which
can help you innovate and save.
We just published a full
guide of different ways
to help you manage
your virtual machines
and save some
money by not paying
for resources you're not using.
From simply pausing
machines that
aren't needed to
building an automated
solution with Recommender,
find the best way to optimize
your usage with this guide.
If you're building an app and
need a relational database,
Cloud SQL has what you need.
It's a fully managed relational
database for MySQL, PostgreSQL
and SQL Server.
And if you're looking for
some tips on how it works
or how to migrate, check
out these resources
from Priyanka and Gabe.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.